foreign
practical for a second though because I
will put a link in the show notes to one
thing I have an article here called the
25 best places to recycle old clothes
that cannot be donated I'm not going to
walk you through all of those because
this is the lightning round right now
but if you head on over to the
minimalists.com podcast we'll put a link
to that article the 25 best places to
recycle old clothes that cannot be
donated however here's something I have
for you
clothes can be recycled question mark
here are five underrated ways to use old
clothes that cannot be donated so it's
true that if you have a lot of old
clothes many of our old clothes still
have tags on them donate those let
someone else get value from them or in a
gently used clothes yeah you can donate
those to your local Goodwill or local
homeless shelters that you can sell them
on eBay I like buy a lot of my shirts
from eBay now because and I'll get them
they're either brand new or the worn
ones didn't fit me well I'm gonna sell
it great it's essentially new at that
point except the price is like fifty
percent ninety percent less than what it
would have been however if you've got a
bunch of clothes that can't be donated
at this point instead of just throwing
them away here are five things you can
do the first thing is I'll put a link to
this article in the show notes as well
first thing you can do is cut or tear
your old clothes up and make them into
Rags for cleaning I've done that a bunch
I mean yeah that makes sense right I
mean they're essentially Rags we even
use that term now right oh look at these
old rags yeah I'll turn them into Rags
that's pretty simple you can dye the
fabric and turn it into something usable
like a hair elastic that's what TK does
or a headband
for those listening it's funny because
he does not have hair on his head
the joke's not funny you have to explain
it Mallory
good night for those who did not get the
joke it was the basis for the humor was
that he's actually bald and visit
Mallory's website jokesexplained.com
the third thing on the list here is use
the textiles as pillow stuffing I
already have stuff in my pillow so I
probably don't need that wear old
stained or damaged clothing for painting
projects or other dirty tasks like yard
work however Ryan be careful with that
because we can justify holding on to
anything oh yeah I did work around the
house and um when I was living in Ohio
and I had you know 20 work shirts and 20
work pairs of jeans and
um I could only wear so many of those
layers at once go back to the pillow
thing though Mariah actually did this
because she bought a pillow that had a
bunch of plastic inside of it oh she
didn't realize it it's because it was
like you know the it was just like it
wasn't microplastic but it was some kind
of plastic that she had so she like took
all the filling out we stuffed it with
old clothes oh wow yeah okay so it is
practical very practical and finally
practice sewing or patch repair this is
what Ella does at her unschool they just
have a bunch of old donated clothes
there and she's messing them all up
sewing things together she's so enclosed
to her hands sometimes but the point is
that if you are wanting to pick up that
skill you're going to need some clothes
that you're able to ruin before you can
get better at it that's a great idea
we'll put a link to that in the show
notes as well we'll check out the
patreon live stream in a moment but
first real quick for right here right
now here's one thing that's going on in
the life of the minimalist three days
only starting today which is the 29th of
May 2023 so three days 72 hours we are
launching our first ever decluttering
course come on yeah
dude we work so hard on this thing oh my
God I might say we I mean Jordan
well a lot this has been been going on
since last year we started planning it
and outlying it last year it's called
simplify everything it starts with the
stuff it's five weeks that first week we
get deep into your physical clutter but
then beyond that we have a week of
digital clutter we have a week of
calendar clutter I'm so busy I don't
know what to do I keep saying yes yes
well we help you with the calendar
clutter as well and then of course
Financial clutter do you have any debt
in your life do you make any irrational
or impulse purchases we help out with
financial clutter and ultimately we end
the course with relationship clutter 17
video lessons 45 clutter problem areas
135 decluttering Solutions a 30 page
workbook student forums and much much
more of less it is called simplify
everything you can find it at simplify
everything dot x y z Ryan earlier you
mentioned your favorite part was the the
relationship clutter a week because it
all sort of builds up to that what
really stood out to you throughout the
course is there any memories as you were
filming it and re-filming it and
re-re-filming it yeah no uh yeah a lot
of memories
um I learned a lot of lessons along the
way like speaking straight to camera is
very different than having a
conversation on a podcast
um so I became much better at uh
learning what I need to do to talk
directly to camera oh he's being bashful
right now like Ryan stole the show when
you go to that first week you're like oh
my gosh do I need to redo everything
because it was like we were one-upping
each other like you know when three
people get a song and they have three
different verses and like they're each
trying to one-up the next person I
wasn't intentionally doing that but then
Ryan comes in and I'm like oh my gosh
his new take is so good what am I
supposed to do with this yeah like once
I learned what I had to do and got my
footing like I do feel really good about
it I have never ever watched anything of
mine and have been like oh Mariah you
got to see this of me until this course
look how awesome this came out TK what
about you my favorite section was the
calendar clutter because it really
forced me to dig in into just how much
busyness is applied in our society right
it it's a badge of honor and it's an
excuse for not being the people we want
to be and for so many of us we feel like
we have these grandiose or satisfying
visions of how we could be living Our
Lives if we weren't so busy and yet we
have a hard time letting go of the
stories around why we're busy and so I
think we provide a lot of value in that
calendar clutter section that resonates
with me very strongly and and what I see
a lot of people out there struggling
with well the website is simplify
everything.xyz the.com was not available
but I figured this is appropriate anyway
right XYZ we're gonna get to the end of
your clutter simplify everything.xyz
it's a five-week course however it's
available for 72 hours only May 29th May
30th May 31st and then if you're
listening to this after that you can
held on over there put your email
address and if we decide to offer this
again in the future I don't know but my
hope is this goes really well we learn a
lot of lessons from this a lot of hard
work went into this so if you'd like to
join you can join simplify everything
dot x y z did you enjoy this Standalone
patreon highlight if so you can listen
to full episodes of the minimalist
private podcast available exclusively on
patreon visit patreon.com the
minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and YouTube Channel 100
advertisement free